[تصفيق]
تستخدم اسرائيل مجموعه من الاسلحه
والانظمه العسكريه في عملياتها ضد قطاع
غزه اخطرها الاسلحه الهجوميه التي تحمل
قدرات تدمير عاليه يستخدمها جيش الاحتلال
ضد مناطق مدنيه ذات كثافه سكانيه عاليه
قنابل ام كي تصنف قنابل متعدده الاغراض
حره الاسقاط غير موجهه تصنع باوزان مختلفه
تبدا من 150 كيلو جراما وتصل الى طن
تقريبا منظومه جيدام وهي قنابل تستهدف
عاده البنيه التحتيه مدنيه او عسكريه وتعد
من ذخائر الهجوم المباشر ولها قدره على
احداث حفره انفجاريه ضخمه جدا وتستطيع
اختراق الارض حتى اربعه امتار قنابل مجنحه
من طراز جي بي يو 39 وهي قنابل موجهه بدقه
تطلق من طائرات اف 16
وتوجه لاستهداف شقق سكنيه او منازل ولها
محيط تدمير يصل لنحو 200 متر
كما تستخدم اسرائيل القذائف المدفعيه
التقليديه غالبا مثل مدافع هاودزر لاطلاق
قذائف من عيار 155 ملم وقذائف دخانيه
ومدافعها عن عيار 120م
وتعتبر من مدافع الميدان ويستخدم الجيش
الاسرائيلي مسيرات هجوميه لالقاء قنابل
موجهه من نوعها الفاير كما تستخدم
المسيرات للمراقبه والتجسس وجمع المعلومات
وتبقى مقاتلات اف 16 الطائرات الاهم التي
يستخدمها جيش الاحتلال في غاراته على
القطاع اضافه لطائرات مروحيه كما استخدمت
اسرائيل سفينه حربيه خلال عمليه ثار
الاحرار واطلقت منها قذائف متوسطه المدى
خلال عمليه ثار الاحرار فعلت اسرائيل
مقلاع داود واعترضت على الاقل صاروخا كان
متجها نحوه الابيب ومقلاع داود هو النظام
دفاع صاروخي صمم الاعتراض الصواريخ التي
يتراوح مداها بين
130 كيلومتر
وتعتمد اسرائيل بشكل اساسي على منظومه
القبه الحديديه وهي منظومه دفاع جوي
متحركه تعمل على تتبع المقذوفات قصيره
المدى بواسطه رادار ثم تحلل البيانات حول
منطقه السقوط المحتمله لترسل احداثيات
لوحده اطلاق الصواريخ لاعتراضها
[موسيقى]